the pirouette sur les ondes de marmites
fm 88 pour à quatre avec lui en direct
sur 88.4 nouradine a nié journalistes
pour marmite fm et au micro et le
recevait cet après-midi-là deux
comédiens qui prépare un festival
d'improvisation théâtrale sur saint
quentin en yvelines dans
l'émission-phare marmite et son actu
d'abord on essaie d'inviter une
personnalité locale qui a une actualité
à chaque émission il ya un journal
d'actualités car la mesure où il est à
préparer donc il ya des reportages qui
sont faits sur sur la semaine ce
programme est présenté en direct tous
les mercredis de 17 heures à 18 heures
en tout ce sont une vingtaine des
missions variées on peut parler autant
de littérature du livre que d'économie
on parle également avec l'émission trapy
blog par exemple de l'actualité des
jeunes de trappes qui ont 15 16 17 ans
et qui ont vu de s'exprimer un petit peu
sur les problématiques qui la
rencontrent au quotidien dans cette
radio 60% des programmes sont réalisés
par des bénévoles c'est l'adn de
marmites fm depuis sa création c'est à
dire que c'est bas des habitants de des
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
qui ont un projet d'émission qui vont
venir nous le soumettre on essaie
vraiment rapidement une fois qu'une
personne est motivée envie de faire la
radio et surtout a quelque chose à dire
eh bien on ouvre la porte on essaie de
lui donner en tout cas les clés de
compréhension de comment marche la radio
puis après c'est parti entre 25 à 30
bénévoles produisent des émissions ou
des chroniques régulièrement la radio
peut également s'écouter sur le site
internet avec tous les podcasts